every president since Harry Truman has
used televised speeches from the Oval
Office to talk about the most important
issues of the day President Trump's
first oval office speech last night
addressed what he called a crisis of the
heart and soul along the u.s. southern
border
he argued that building a border wall is
absolutely critical for security and
humanitarian reasons mr. Trump
criticized Democrats in Congress for
refusing to spend billions on the
project House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
Senate Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
responded saying the president
manufactured a border crisis they
accused him of holding the American
people hostage in a partial government
shutdown major Garrett is at the White
House to untangle at all forest major
good morning good morning president
Trump's first addressed from the Oval
Office in summary said the following the
flow of undocumented immigrants illegal
drugs and human trafficking at the
southern border right now constitutes a
national crisis the primetime platform
was new the arguments very very familiar
notably absent any new proposals from
the President or any hint of concessions
that might resolve the ongoing partial
government shutdown this is a
humanitarian crisis a crisis of the
heart and a crisis of the soul looking
to sway public opinion in the government
shutdown battle president Trump argued
illegal immigration at the southern
border hurts all Americans it strains
public resources and drives down jobs
and wages he also claimed it's an issue
of criminality in the last two years ice
officers made 266 thousand arrests of
aliens with criminal records of the 266
thousand arrests most were for
nonviolent offenses including more than
80,000 traffic violations the president
also made an emotional appeal as he
mentioned the families of victims killed
by illegal immigrants I've held the
hands of the weeping mothers and
embraced the grief-stricken fathers mr.
Trump used the nine and a half minute
address to further entrench his position
in the shutdown battle he wants 5.7
billion dollars in wall funding and is
refusing to back down from fulfilling a
signature campaign
promised this barrier is absolutely
critical to border security the
president argued the southern border is
a pipeline for illegal drugs including
heroin but it is unclear how a wall
would address the problem a 2018 report
from the DEA says drug trafficking is
concentrated at legal ports of entry not
remote stretches of the border Democrats
in Congress have refused to acknowledge
the crisis the speech included little
effort at outreach mr. Trump blamed
Democrats for the shutdown which has
affected 800,000 federal workers the
federal government remains shut down for
one reason and one reason only because
Democrats will not fund border security
a false claim as Democrats voted last
week for 1.3 billion dollars in border
security including physical barriers and
technology on the border just not the
wall funding mr. Trump requested the
president is rejecting these bipartisan
bills which would reopen government in
their rebuttal following the president
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer said the
debate over the wall should be separate
so the government can reopen this
president just used the backdrop of the
Oval Office to manufacture a crisis
stoke fear and divert attention from the
turmoil in his administration Democrats
haven't always been against funding a
southern barrier in 2006 Senator Schumer
and other Democrats supported
legislation for fencing on the border
the symbol of America should be the
Statue of Liberty not a 30-foot wall
President Trump has been publicly toying
with the idea of declaring all of this a
national emergency which might give him
the authority to siphon construction
funds from the Pentagon budget to begin
or accelerate construction of the border
wall and a bit of an anti-climax
bianna no mention of that in last
night's primetime address big question
about what legal ramifications that
would have had maybe that's why he
didn't mention it major thank you